[Music]
we know that the rational number is a
number that can be expressed as P by Q
where Q is not equal to zero this is the
traditional definition an example would
be 9/2 but nine by two can be written as
four point five what does this form yes
it's called the decimal form every
decimal number can be expressed in a
decimal form this is a very important
point any rational number can be written
in decimal form but what kind of decimal
form can it be written in are there
different types yes let's look at them
there are two broad categories
terminating decimals and non terminating
decimals examples of terminating decimal
numbers are zero point five two or two
point seven five the digits after the
decimal point
terminate they do not go on and on and
on non terminating is again classified
into two types recurring decimals and
non-recurring decimals recurring would
be something like zero point six six six
six six and so on it does not terminate
and the number six is repeated
indefinitely since it's repeated it's
called recurring even something like two
point seven seven seven seven seven
seven and so on is a recurring non
terminating decimal since it does not
end and the number seven is repeated
indefinitely but does it mean only one
digit can repeat indefinitely no look at
eighteen point five two five two five
two and so on here five two is repeated
indefinitely after the decimal since
five two is repeated indefinitely and it
does not end it's called non terminating
recurring decimal also does it mean that
the repeating part starts immediately
after the decimal point no let's look at
seven point six five two three two three
two
three and so on here the number two
three is repeated and goes on forever
but the decimal path starts with six
five even such numbers are classified as
non terminating recurring decimals the
non terminating recurring category forms
a very important category in decimal
representation we will look at just this
category in one of our videos non
terminating non-recurring simply means
that the number does not end and the
digits after the decimal point do not
have a specific pattern the best example
would be pi 3.14159 and so on the number
does not end and even if you have
hundred digits after the decimal point
you will not find any pattern or any
indefinite repetition of digits here's
the value of pi up to hundred digits
look at the digits carefully you will
see no pattern whatsoever in here that
is the reason it's called non-recurring
you can even form non recurring decimals
on your own something like six point two
zero three zero zero three zero zero
zero three zero zero zero zero and so on
there you go you will not find any
pattern here or maybe something like
eleven point six seven one seven one one
seven one one one seven one one one one
and so on you take any two-digit number
like thirty and write it by repeating
the unit's digit again the unit's digit
is zero so we write a three zero zero
and then we add the unit's digit again
and write three zero zero zero here we
took seven one then seven one one then
seven and 11 this is just one of the
easiest ways in which you can do it you
may also take three digits and continue
writing them accordingly but here's the
main point of the video terminating
decimals and non terminating recurring
decimals together form rational numbers
nonterminating non-repeating decimals
cannot be expressed as P by
q which is why they are not rational
numbers
you
[Music]